there's a new way of life that is
Dawning upon me which is really trying
to suck the marrow out of life treating
every moment as sacred which means doing
your absolute best in everything and
being super prepared super aware super
present for it just means that for every
moment that you are having you're there
for that moment and you're extracting
the most from that moment that you
possibly can which really just boils
down to constant awareness it's not a
watch word like being present it's
making sure that literally every moment
you have on this planet whether it's
with your children whether it's relaxing
whether it's reading it's deliberate
it's conscious it's aware and it's done
in such a way that you are fully there
mamoto Masashi famously said do nothing
that is of no use as life gets shorter
and shorter each moment becomes more and
more precious if you like animated
videos like this check out media plog
using the link in my bio